how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some
really big news we finally have some
type of direction that marvel studios is
going to go with
black panther 2 including when they're
going to start
filming and apparently the actor that is
going to be playing the main villain of
the film
has been revealed and then in a separate
report it looks like not only are we
going to get
one black panther in the film but there
are also going to be
two new black panthers coming in black
panther too i'll break down everything
that you need to know if you're new be
sure to subscribe to stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a zombie hulk
funko pop provided by heroes
hideouts.com i'll be announcing the
winner next friday
so i think a lot of us were expecting
black panther 2 to be delayed a very
long time due to the passing of chadwick
boseman
but it seemingly appears that marvel
studios does have their plans in order
and at least have an idea of how they're
going to move forward with the sequel
now black panther 2 was scheduled for
may 6th of 2022 and although it might
not be delayed years
this may not be the release date that it
comes out but there is the possibility
that marvel studios could be sticking to
this date as today we have a report on
when the film is going to start
filming last night the internet kind of
went crazy when the hollywood reporter
reported this in an article
they said multiple sources tell the
hollywood reporter that marvel is now
readying
black panther 2 for a shoot that will
start in atlanta in july
and last for upwards of six months
so they're going to start filming
according to this report in july of 2020
it's going to take
six months which will last until january
which would give them four months of
post-production and editing before the
may release date
now that is cutting it kind of close as
far as a production schedule goes
but it can be done however if they
decide to push the release date back a
few months that will kind of be expected
at this point
but the report goes on to say mexican
actor tanak huerta who was one of the
stars on netflix's narcos
mexico is in talks to play one of the
antagonists
sources tell the hollywood reporter now
as far as which villain he could be
playing that's kind of a shot in the
dark at this point but some could argue
that he could indeed be
plain namor the submariner at this point
we don't really have enough information
to tell but
they go on to report that leticia wright
lupita nyong'o
winston duke and angelo bessette are
expected to return for the new film
with reports stating that leticia
wright's character shuri
is going to take on a more prominent
role now i think at this point everybody
is expecting shuri to become the new
black panther
and this does happen in the comics and
there is a really good way to set this
up in the movie
and the comics shuri and t'challa both
challenged their uncle for the title of
black panther t'challa won but he
promised to train his sister in combat
so if a day should come when she needs
to lead wakanda she could take his place
and it does seem like that day is going
to come sometime during black panther 2.
however we also do have a report stating
that there is going to be
two black panthers in a report from
grace randolph she said
still hearing shuri will be black
panther alongside a male black panther
still betting it will be a new guy in
the suit i want embaku and t'challa will
get killed at the beginning of the film
i will say if this ends up being true it
makes a lot of sense
because a lot of people a lot of young
people specifically
did look up to t'challa and black
panther as a role model
and it would be a shame to take black
panther away from all of those kids
but at the same time having a male black
panther and then adding a
female black panther would be great
because then you would have role models
for both boys and girls so this seems
like it would be a very good strategy
for marvel and disney to do
now it has basically been confirmed by
marvel studios executive vice president
that
t'challa is actually already dead in the
mcu now whether we'll get much
explanation for that in black panther 2
is to be determined but i for one don't
think that he should die
on screen but i do like the idea of
having two black panthers in the marvel
cinematic universe both having different
roles of course but let me know what you
think about this news
black panther 2 is going to start
filming in july which is a lot sooner
than i think a lot of us thought it
would start
we have a possibility for an actor to
play the villain and there is a
possibility that we could be getting two
black panthers so let me know what you
think about all of this news in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and black panther
2 news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you